buonasera
sono qui perché ho seguito il mio cuore
venti mesi fa
ero a toronto dove un mio amico
ingegnere strutturale che ha costruito
quello edificio va messo un libro in
mano
l'ho letto
era di il suo architetto preferito
allora l'ho letto due volte mi sono
innamorato e ho lasciato tutto per
venire qui a firenze con la certezza di
scrivere una sceneggiatura
sono venuto a firenze per capire meglio
il passato ma quello che ho trovato a
grande rivelanza al nostro futuro
collettivo
la storia di una città
igenio filippo brunelleschi e la sua
cupola meravigliosa
forse anche ho trovato un nuovo segreto
della cupola
la cupola di brunelleschi era ricca di
tecnologia
era infatti
l'internet del rinascimento
le statistiche della cupola fanno
impressione
29.000 tonnellate di pietra di mattone
di legno
creato senza computer
senza necessità solo qui il cervello coi
mani
l'eco filo e piombo
esistevano grandissimi problemi come
fare sollevare
mille tonnellate di pietra un cantiere
alto di 66 metri ma l'hanno fatto e
l'hanno fatto tutto e vi dico questo
la cupola del brunelleschi era molto di
più
era un cantiere vivo pieno di idee di
filosofia di matematica e scienza e
all'inizio la cupola di brunelleschi era
un concetto doveva essere inventata come
l'internet doveva essere inventata
l'internet non esiste senza fili di
telefono computer modem e roba del
genere è per costruire la cupola filippo
brunelleschi e inventato macchine
calze e il metodo di lavorare e che è
successo dopo 25 anni tutte le idee il
lavoro che è messo dentro la cupola anno
un dato a nastro il prossimo generazione
cervelli come michelangelo
e leonardo da vinci
è una cosa strana
senza tutte le opere
risolti da brunelleschi sulla cupola
michelangelo non aveva le base per le
sue opere
la cupola come l'internet ha portato
avanti informazione per la prossima
generazione
e dopo 25 anni dell'internet io oggi
come regista o nelle mie mani cine
riprese digitale suono editing final cut
è il metodo di portare le mie storie a
tutto il mondo
c'è un'altra cosa molto importante
grandi idee come la cupola
hanno stimolato una grande
collaborazione
la città di firenze ha riuniti i suoi
migliori cittadini uomini d'affari
artigiani
gente che lavoravano con immani era
fatto due domande
not now when
he se non noi chi
vi domando si può immaginare la città di
firenze
senza la cupola al centro del suo cuore
la palla è la croce sono diventate fari
universale per tutto il mondo per il
pensiero per la democrazia
è ora siamo all'inizio di una nuova
epoca
la gente guarda non internet anziché
leggerlo
i nostri bambini
imparano a vedere e puoi fare come gli
artigiani umanisti dell'epoca
io credo che la tecnologia e la cosa
perché noi viviamo è importante come
l'amore come la cittadinanza è come la
vita sociale
questo uomo ma ha dato grande
ispirazione
quando ha iniziato il progetto della
cupola aveva 42 anni come me ora e non
ha ancora iniziato il suo capolavoro una
cosa che nessuno voleva fare
guarda
il mio film non potrà mai mai mai mai
superare l'immensità
della cupola ma forse posso
davanti al mondo
onerare questo figlio fiorentino un
genio che ha portato grande fortuna a
questa bellissima città
viva firenze è viva filippo brunelleschi
grazie